[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW TOY: My
name is Andrew Toy.
I'm a product management
director with the Android
and Chrome team.
And today I'm going to talk
to you about Google on Google.
Basically, how do we
manage devices and security
and secure access
within Google itself?
So when I'm talking
about Google.
I mean Google as in Googlers,
our own employees, access
to our own data, our own code.
If you were to come
and work at Google,
how do you get a device
and things like that?
We're not talking about
necessarily our products,
though we do use our own
products as part of this.
So our own IT department,
our own IT sec department.
Quick poll.
I know people don't really
love this, but just put up
your hands if you work in IT.
A lot of IT folks.
Maybe a subset of that, but if
you're in the security part,
like CESO office or sec
ops or anything like that.
OK.
So a handful of security
people going there.
And one last hands up.
Hands up if your
company and you are
responsible for working with
your own MDM or EMM or UEM
solutions from that regard?
OK, cool.
Thank you very much.
That just helps me
calibrate a little bit
what we're talking about today.
So, why device
management matters?
Since a lot of you are
from an IT audience,
you guys understand why
device management matters.
I work a lot with our
own corp eng department.
And obviously we need control.
We need access.
We can't just let
data flow willy nilly.
We need to know where our
data is being accessed from,
how it's being accessed.
It's about security.
It's about management.
It's about control.
Today everything I talk about
is our general principles
of how we manage our endpoints.
So yes, I come from a
phone and tablet side,
but we're including laptops in
there because what we're seeing
is that while laptops and
desktops have been around
for much longer,
and there's always
been ways to update and
fix them with patching
and with things like big fix the
images and flashing, what we're
seeing is that the modern way
of doing management, which
is through a set
of management APIs,
through strict
data of separation,
through security by default,
through rigorous app
stores for app
deployment, that's
the way we see endpoint
management going
across all endpoints,
all the way
through certainly
mobile and tablets
and through laptops
and desktops,
but even all the way through
to IOT, the internet of things.
So this isn't the IOT talk.
I also cover that.
I'm happy to answer questions
about that if folks have them.
Why do we really need this?
Well, a lot of things have
changed in the last few years.
Since the upcoming advent of
mobile, a lot of new groups
have sprung up, a lot
of new technologies.
A lot of new vendors
have come to us and said,
hey, we do device management,
and this is how you go.
A lot of you, your EMM or
MVM will be coming to you
and saying, well, I
used to do just mobile,
but I want to do your laptops.
I want to do all
of your endpoints
as we move to a UEM, unified
endpoint management world.
So all this won't
be new to you folks.
We're trying to manage
a lot of this complexity
and say, how do we have a
principle that overrides
and runs through all of
our various endpoints
so we're not solving things
in an individual way?
And something I always
said is that mobile is not
its own thing.
Mobile was its own thing
for the last few years.
We have mobile
groups spinning up.
We have mobile application
developers, mobile device
management vendors.
But really, mobile is
kind of like what internet
was in the early 2000s.
In the early 2000s, late '90s,
the internet was very new.
A lot of companies said, well,
we need an internet division
and an internet group.
And I'm going to
have an internet part
of my company, an
internet set of people
who work on that stuff.
But what happened was
everything is internet, right?
Internet is interwoven into the
fabric of all of our companies.
And that's the same
thing about mobile.
Mobile is more just about
the proliferation of devices,
the proliferation of access,
the proliferation of networks
onto cellular networks,
which breaks down
the old models of how we
used to do things in IT.
So one of the reasons
I give this talk,
and I was introducing myself
as a product director,
I ran Android for Work, which is
part of the initiative to bring
Android into the enterprise.
But I also ran a mobile
application security
and development at Morgan
Stanley for over five years.
So I've sat on
both sides of this.
And so I think very
carefully about what
it's like to be
within an organization
and trying to manage
this complexity,
and saying what I
would do if I were you
folks in the modern world.
So how do we do
things at Google,
and why is it a
little bit different?
First of all, we definitely
have an open culture.
And this open culture
means that we tend
to lean towards failing open.
That means that we
don't have this idea of,
OK, well, I have my walls,
I have my buildings,
I have my internet.
I'm going to go ahead
and lock into that
and manage everything
through those gardens.
Who here is familiar with
our BeyondCorp initiative
and has read some
of those papers?
OK, great.
What I would recommend
for everybody is that you
familiarize
yourself, BeyondCorp,
C-O-R-P is what
you'll want to Google,
look around for materials.
I think we have a link at the
end of the deck for it as well.
BeyondCopr is something
that I would absolutely
familiarize yourself with
if I was working today,
which is Google's
VPN-less intranet-less way
of approaching how we
deploy applications.
Yes, we are cloud centric.
Yes, we are cloud native.
We have a ton of advantages.
But the principles apply to
every company, which is really
the idea of being
secure and safe
and managed because
you're on your intranet,
those days are
rapidly going behind.
That's an old model.
It's reaching the end of its
lifetime is what we believe.
So here at Google, we
actually do have an intranet.
We have Google A, for
example, for our Wi-Fi,
which is an intranet.
And we have Google Guest.
But I will say
that on my laptop,
I can't remember the last time
I needed to be on my intranet
to access anything special.
Oftentimes if I'm like, oh, I've
got a little bit of a problem
on Google A, I'll just
jump over to Google Guest
and keep right on working.
I don't re-fire up a VPN.
I don't do anything.
I just keep on going.
I can bring my laptop
from the intranet,
pick it up, take it home.
Once again, no VPN, nothing.
All the security is done
through HTTP, through certs.
I'll talk more about
that in a minute.
But the idea is that's
the experience we're
trying to give to Googlers.
It's not, well, where am I,
and what network am I on,
and how do I access things?
We try to make all of that go
away so people could just get
their work done immediately.
So we fail to this idea of
really good user experiences
and are willing to really
push the boundaries of moving
past the traditional
comfort zones of IT
to make sure that when
people are able to work
in this way, of course
security is paramount to us,
but we are up for doing the
extra engineering we need
to make sure we have
security and we have access.
So just talking about
that, we're very aware.
We're Google.
We have Gmail.
When people look at how people
are getting hacked and stuff
about phishing, we take
security extremely, extremely,
extremely seriously.
This is a theme of Next, and
hopefully all of you guys
are getting it.
We are very aware
that professionals
are being targeted.
I come from Morgan Stanley.
I know from financial services,
very high value targets
for phishing, for
social engineering,
for people trying to
get in with malware.
Very aware of all
of these targets.
So security throughout
this talk is
absolutely paramount to
everything that we do.
We have a group internally
for analysts, for detection,
for response, for prevention
on all of our endpoints.
So when I tell you
something like,
hey, we don't need
to have an intranet,
it's not because
we're just taking
and throwing
security to the wind,
it's because we have a new way
of approaching these problems.
And by the way, I'll have
room for questions at the end
where you'll be to ask them.
But if you want to just stick
up your hand at any point,
I'm happy to take questions
throughout the presentation.
So this is Urs.
You might have heard
him speak again.
Urs runs our technical
infrastructure team.
And he also owns the IT and
internal Corporate Engineering
department, which we
refer to as corp eng.
And we, I think, often say this.
And when I worked in IT, we
would say this all the time.
But I want to refocus
everyone in the room,
because I think this
is something we want
to keep in front of our minds.
IT and security is an enabler.
It should not be something
that restricts what you can do.
Security is what
enables you to do stuff.
In your personal lives,
when you pay for something
with your credit card,
you are aware that this
feels like a generally
secure way to pay, right?
Like even though there is
credit card fraud out there,
you're not dealing with
fraud on a day to day basis.
Oh my god, I can't
pay at this restaurant
because they might steal
my credit card number.
Hopefully you're not.
And because you have
that sense of security,
and because of
all that work that
has gone into the
security of payments,
you feel very comfortable
using your credit card
in a lot of different scenarios.
So that's the kind
of feeling you
want to have as you work through
and as your users want to have,
is that they know
they're secure,
so they get this freedom
and this liberation
to actually do more.
Too often security ends up
just being a gate or a blocker.
No offense to the security
people in the room,
but oftentimes when
we talk to customers,
we talk to the IT side,
they say, oh, well, we'll
have to get this through
our security department.
And what we try to say is, let's
try to get to a relationship
where security in
IT are collaborating
to say how do we explore the
art of the possible while
still keeping it
absolutely secure.
So these are the
three dimensions
of what we really feel.
On the one hand,
there's security.
IT security,
information security,
you may have the same department
who does both of those things.
It might be a
different department
who does info sec from sec ops.
Definitely there's usability,
and I talked about that.
I think we all intuitively
know what usability is.
And there's also privacy.
And this is a really
important part of the puzzle
as well, because if you
share all of your information
all of the time,
and you actually
surrender all of your
privacy as an individual,
it actually makes the security
person's job a lot easier,
to be honest.
But that's not necessarily
what employees want to do.
And that's something we need
to take into account as well.
Even though we all have
the big terms of services
that can flash up and say, you
have no expectation of privacy,
we can access all
your information
while you're on net.
Yes, of course, the company
can do all those things.
The company shouldn't
necessarily do all those things
unless it really has to.
So these are the three
pillars that we think about,
security, usability and privacy.
And while we recognize that it's
always a little bit of a push
and pull in each direction,
part of the art and the science
here is finding a way to
find the right blend of all
those things so that you
can have a wonderful access
strategy internally, one
that you're excited about.
This is part of what we
were going to go here.
I worked on mobile in the
sort of pure BlackBerry days,
the days when it was
like, well, that's it.
BlackBerry did a great
job solving this problem.
We're going to deploy
our BlackBerrys.
It's going to be BlackBerry
through and through.
We're going to run
the BES server.
We're going to just
give out BlackBerrys.
All good.
And that was on the
one hand liberating,
because this was a mobile
strategy for the first time
that IT could take and say,
wow, we agree this is secure.
This is great.
Let's deploy it.
Let's give mobile access to
all of these employees who
never had it.
On the other hand, it
was semi constraining.
Because what actually was
happening was all the strategy
was being deferred
to effectively one
company, RIM, Research in
Motion, who makes BlackBerry.
And so when you do
that, basically you're
outsourcing your strategy
to a vendor in that case.
You're like, my
strategy is BlackBerry.
Which is kind of a strategy,
but actually what you're saying
is my strategy is
BlackBerry's strategy,
and they go hand-in-hand.
And what happened
was is that, great,
yes to everything BlackBerry,
no to everything else.
And that was fine
because BlackBerry really
was a very good device.
When the iPhone came
around, that kind of blew up
that model a lot.
You couldn't really go to
the business stakeholders
and say, oh, well,
you know what?
It's just BlackBerry,
BlackBerry.
Some people still can.
I know of customers who are
still in that world even today.
But most companies
have now moved
to a world where they're
like, well, listen,
this is not the way we can
run our strategy anymore.
We have to be able
to at least do iOS.
And a lot of companies
just say, you know what?
For BYOD, we're going to support
iOS and flavors of Android.
This is how we want
to run our strategy.
So really, you need to embrace
mobility and embrace access
and feel comfortable that you
are covered in all regards,
and not just say
this is my strategy.
It's restricted
devices and that's it.
Because even if you can find
a good middle ground today
and say, you know what,
it's not just BlackBerry,
it's BlackBerry and
iPhone, technology
keeps on rolling forward.
There'll soon be another
killer device, another killer
platform, another way
of approaching it.
How are you going
to do IOT sensors?
How are you going to do ML
when people want to access data
from their assistant units which
are sitting in their Google
homes?
Technology keeps pushing and
pushing and pushing and pushing
us to be able to have more
access for our company in more
esoteric places all the time.
I would not say that the answer
is not to just sort of say,
well, it's this, then
it's this plus this,
then it's this plus
this plus this.
You want a strategy that
embraces and allows you
to approach everything at once.
So how do we think
about access control?
We break everything down and
we say, well, first of all,
let's make sure we have
a really good idea of how
we think of our people.
This is going to be your
identity strategy, your IAM
strategy.
Devices, which is endpoints and
the state of those endpoints
and how they're
managed and what data
is going to those endpoints.
And this is the one that
people often overlook,
even though it's
the most important
and probably should be the
most obvious one, applications.
How do we think
of and categorize
our various
applications, so we can
decide what's appropriate
to access at any given time
and where?
On device management,
we actually
centralized all
these concepts so
that we are able
to control and have
knobs to say this is what can
be accessed from where on which
data device.
So again, we move away from the
monolithic concept of on net,
off net, on VPN, off VPN,
on mobile, off mobile.
Too many of those
variables makes
it impossible to
solve the equation.
What we instead said is, let's
identify general security
and access postures, tiers.
We call it tiered access.
I have a slide on
that coming up.
How do we generalize it
into those categories?
How do we know
which applications
go into which category?
And then let's just define
in any given moment in time
which state a given endpoint
and user combination is in.
And are they in a
good enough state
that we're willing to give
access to a given application?
It's actually pretty simple
when I describe it that way,
but that's just a general
mantra that we go through.
On the people level,
we want to make sure
that a given identity has access
to the right applications.
So this is fairly
simple stuff, but you've
got to make sure
that you actually
have this deployed properly
in your environment, which
is maybe you're in HR.
And so you should therefore
be able to say, OK, well
I should be able to
see the actual employee
records of a whole bunch
of different people.
I should be to go in and
log into the application
and see those employee records.
OK, fantastic.
Maybe you should only see
it for your department.
Maybe you shouldn't see it
for the entire organization.
Maybe you're not in
HR, you shouldn't
be able to see those
records unless you are
the manager of those people.
Most of your companies
should have these concepts
already in place.
I'm just making
sure that we have it
for the sake of completeness.
But for HR, you might
have those in place,
but you might not have
those in other applications.
The idea is for HR, you're like,
well, that makes total sense.
We should do it for payroll.
Well yeah, I'm going
to do it there.
That makes total sense.
But you've to go through your
population of applications
and make sure that
for each application,
you have an idea of who should
be able to access it and when.
On the devices standpoint--
so we did all that for
our internal applications.
On the devices standpoint
here at Google,
just because people
ask these questions,
we support a variety
of different devices.
We support Android.
And on Android, we support our
pixel devices and any Nexus
device at the highest
tier of access.
We also support Chrome OS at
the highest tier of access.
And we support
Mac OS and Windows
at our highest tier of access.
So we actually support
our entire population.
When a Googler
comes in, you might
think that every Googler
gets an Android device.
But you'll see that
a lot of Googlers
are actually carrying
around iOS devices.
And I'll explain what
their experience is
like versus an Android device.
You'll see a lot of Googlers
carrying Mac devices.
Few are carrying Windows.
But they have those as well.
Lot of us carry Chrome.
Actually, it's a completely
individual decision
by every Googler which
device they want to get.
You can just go to
the internal portal
and say this is
the device I want.
If you want when your
hardware refresh cycle is up,
you can say, you know what?
I've been on Mac OS.
I want to go to
Chrome OS for a while.
And you can absolutely do that.
All of these platforms are
supported at the highest tier.
We have the most amount of trust
in these particular platforms.
From an application
standpoint, we
use a variety of applications.
Obviously, we are a G Suite
customer-- a very, very big G
Suite customer.
And we have all
those applications.
And then we have-- and this
is kind of interesting.
We do not have generically
named app applications.
Like they probably do have
names on the other side.
But we have the usual
third-party applications,
which we also have access to.
And we build across all of
those using our Google identity.
So I don't know if
people are on G Suite.
But if you're on G
Suite, you'll know
that you can center your
entire identity on that Google
identity.
When you log into
various cloud services,
you can say log in with
your Google identity.
We completely
centralized around that.
And that allows us
to taxonomize which
applications we can get
access to at any given time.
So how do we bring
these concepts together
and sort of set the access?
So I mentioned this before.
And this is like a
really key point, right?
Tiered access-- this
is one of those areas
where having more
granular settings
actually allows you to
have access much more
flexibility in actually how you
grant access to certain things.
So I've often had a
conversation with C-level folks
from very big corporations
who just sort of say
to me, Android, yes or no?
Secure or not secure, right?
Should I allow access
or not allow access?
And we're like, hmm.
Or they'll say, BYOD, yes or no?
Secure or not secure?
Should I allow access
or not allow access?
And it's kind of
an awkward question
to answer, right, because
it shouldn't be this binary,
secure or not secure, right?
One of the answers-- and
I'm the Android guy, right--
is like, I said, listen,
I think BYOD is secure.
And I can show you
how to make it secure.
They're like, got
it, boom, secure.
And I'm like, wait, hold on.
Before you take
the secure box, I
will say that I personally
would be extremely uncomfortable
if your military generals are
carrying around nuclear codes
on their BYOD phone, right?
Really uncomfortable.
I don't think you
should give out
nuclear codes to BYOD devices.
Then they're like, got it--
insecure.
And I'm like, OK, no.
Like, please don't think
about it in this way, right?
It's just not-- it
can't be these two boxes
because it depends on what kind
of data you're carrying, right?
So while most
companies hopefully
do not have nuclear codes, there
are those crown jewel pieces
of data that you
might want to have.
So even though you
treat BYOD as secure,
it would be not
unreasonable for you
to give out dedicated corporate
tablets to your board.
So that for boards
of directors meetings
you can get the most
privileged information
to the board of
directors without having
to worry about and solve
a bunch of BYOD concerns.
And that doesn't mean
you don't do BYOD.
It just means you have to have
a nuanced, granular strategy
to an approach.
And so we do tiered access.
The way that tiered
access works is
that we classify the internal
services, like I said.
That means that we declare
what's in the crown jewel
category, the nuclear codes.
We categorize [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, you know what?
We probably need to know
that you're a Googler.
And we need to know
that, in general,
that you're in good standing
and all those kinds of things.
And once we have that,
that's good enough.
And we also [INAUDIBLE]
categorize, eh, we're
just fine with this.
Like, they can just
access that data,
and it totally makes sense.
Also, in order for
this to work, we
have to know what state
your devices are in.
We have to know to
help us do security.
And we also-- and
this is implied.
I'm not going to talk about
it specifically here--
need to centralize access.
So while we don't have the
VPN, we do have something--
and [INAUDIBLE],
once again, talked
about exactly what we do here.
We do centralize all the
access to our services.
So I'm going to just
skip over this for now
and talk about the
centralization.
In the centralization, we
have access control engines
and trust inferrers that
sit between the endpoints
and access to all
of our applications.
Now, remember, we
are cloud native.
We completely admitted this is
one of our biggest strengths
is that since everything
sits in the cloud,
there's a limited
number of protocols.
It's like almost everything
flows over HTTP and HTPS,
right?
So we're able to limit
access to our services
by having a limited
number of protocols
and a limited number
of ports and all
this kind of good stuff.
So while we don't have a
traditional internet-exernet
service, what we've done
is move that concept
into the application layer.
So our actual HTTP and our
proxies and our actual servers
are able to be aware of
the state of a device
before granting that access
over to a particular service
on the back end.
And the services are
themselves also aware
of the endpoint accessing them.
So we're not saying we have to
issue you a private IP in order
for this to actually work.
It's not a
network-level concept.
And the same exact proxies
are used to access services,
no matter which network I'm on.
The only thing that changes
is the level of trust changes.
Because we're able to analyze
when I'm on a Starbucks
network, yes, that is a
different security posture
than when I'm on my
home network, which
is a different security posture
than when I'm on my intranet.
That is definitely true.
But we don't use on a
on-net/off-net model to try
and define the access
model from that point.
So we do have this.
If you look at-- we've actually
launched a publicly available
version of this which is called
our Gateway product, which
was launching here at Next.
It's coming into beta
and a trusted tester.
And it's something where we
make this proxy technology
available to other customers.
Combined with the
actual proxy here,
the Gatekeeper,
what we actually use
is a trust engine, an
access control engine
which is saying, all
right, so I have everything
funneled through now.
It's all gone
through my proxies.
It's protecting my services.
I know how secure my service is.
So what do I want to do in
terms of actually granting
access or not granting access?
And in this case, here are a
few examples of what we do.
We actually are always
collecting data,
and we collect this data
using our own internal EMM.
So we actually use
the use G Suite
EM to do it, plus some
tools that we developed
and scripts we developed.
So this is collecting
logs, endpoint status,
reporting on what's
going on the endpoint,
reporting what applications
are on the endpoint,
seeing whether we think there's
any known malware there--
lots and lots and
lots of data, which
is being collected from our
endpoints at all times--
and actually saying, OK,
what is the level of trust
we put on this
particular device?
And therefore, in
real time, we can
adjust the security posturing
of those particular devices.
So if today we suddenly find
out, hey, you know what?
There's a newly discovered
class of malware
running on our Windows
laptops, for example.
We didn't know
about it yesterday.
We know about it today.
We can actually-- instead
of saying, well, we
will go on and say,
let's go and scan
and let's flash and
remove malware and make
sure we do that in the fleet.
But to make sure we have
immediate protection,
we can say, let's change
the trust engine to say
that if we know that this
particular application is
installed on a Windows
machine, no longer allow access
from that Windows machines to
are most secure technology,
right?
So therefore, because
that's actually in our cloud
and on the endpoint who's
determining the access,
we are able to move them down.
And that that user can
probably still get email.
They can still do
their regular work.
But they might not be
able to access the crown
jewels at that point
until they're remediated.
And then once
they're remediated,
they can get access
again to everything else.
So we collect all of this data.
And we're able to crunch it.
We use machine learning.
We use our-- we have a
security analyst team.
We have a lot of
different teams.
You can imagine what we're
doing there to make sure
that everything is working.
So tiers of access--
let's sort of get down
to some brass tacks.
There's actually another
tier here called untrusted.
But we're getting rid of that.
So there's minimally
trusted, mostly trusted,
and fully trusted, right?
Very easy language to use.
You can map this.
You can take it, use
at your own company.
You can map it to something.
Minimally trusted
is basic access.
And what we mean by that
is stuff where you're like,
OK, you need to do your job.
And to be really honest, if
someone who's not a Googler
looked at this stuff, it's not
really the end of the world,
right?
But it's not just
the most basic stuff.
But it's just stuff where don't
really try and care too much.
Definitely stuff like
our bus schedules
would be in there, right?
Our menu and cafeteria
access in there.
That's in there.
But interestingly,
and a lot of customers
find this interesting,
we actually
put email in that
category as well,
because we find email to
be extensional for someone
to actually get their job done.
And so we want them to be
able to get their job done
in a lot of different places.
So emails, doc sheets
and slides are actually
all in the minimally
trusted category.
So if you bring in
BYOD today to Google,
you can bring in
any BYOD to phone.
And you can get your email
on that phone, right?
I know a lot of you probably
have like an approach where
you can't do that.
You can do that.
We trust that.
We trust the Gmail
suite of applications.
We trust G Suite and
the inherent security
built into the cloud to
keep all of that stuff safe.
Mostly trusted is normal access.
And what we mean by
that is, OK, we're
going to have a stronger
position around exactly
what your identity is.
We can have a better idea about
the state your device is in.
You should get access
to most applications
to get your job done if you're
sitting in mostly trusted.
You shouldn't have to go to
all the way to fully trusted
in order to get your job done.
Because I know people are
probably already thinking,
oh, OK, well, that must
mean that fully trusted
is the best tier.
We must put everything
into fully trusted,
and then just, oh, I'm done.
But if you do that, once
again, you don't really
have a tiered strategy, right?
You, once again, have
the binary strategy,
where you're either full
or you're not fully.
And if you're not
fully, then you're
just a straight-up
second-class citizen.
That's not our approach.
Our approach is if
we're doing a good job,
you should be able to do the
vast majority of your job day
to day, sitting in a
mostly trusted tier.
And you should be able to
most of your job sitting
in a minimally trusted--
a good amount of your job in
the minimally trusted tier.
But certain things you might
have to go to fully trusted on.
So as an example,
when I go home,
I need to have a
two-factor authentication
to get into mostly
trusted, right?
But I can take my
two-factor authentication,
and I can use it with
my home computer.
That's my computer that I own.
And so it's not imaged.
It's not flashed.
It's not anything like that.
It also doesn't give up
a lot of logs or anything
back to Google.
I can put my
two-factor token in.
I can get into that middle
mostly trusted state,
and I can do the vast
majority of my job
on that particular computer
when I work from home.
[INAUDIBLE], again,
very simple examples--
cafe menu, probably totally
fine to be at that lower tier.
There's not a lot you're
going to do with that.
But I'm not going to be
able to go and check even
my own payroll status from
that particular device.
And I'm not going to
be able to go and check
in code, download
code, certainly not
push the production machines.
Again, that middle tier, where
I'm able to do most of my job--
and remember, I'm
not an engineer.
So when I say most of my job, I
don't need to code for a living
because this isn't my product.
But tighter controls there.
And we have applications
that sit in that category,
so now I can access more
private, more secure
information, where really
being me is important.
Remember, now it
requires two-factor
in order to get in there.
So OK, wonderful, shorter
lived access tokens,
shorter lived identity
tokens, requires two factors
to get in there.
But now if you do
all those things,
you're able to go in and
check payroll and do--
I can approve expense
reports and those kind
of things in that category.
And finally-- the last tier,
again, based on your business,
all these things will apply.
For us, our crown
jewels, we're Google,
our crown jewels is
our code and our cloud
and our production base, right?
So we do require you to be
on a fully trusted, fully
interrogated machine
in order to be
able to access that data to do
those things here at Google.
So how are we actually
doing this on laptops?
I referred to
mobile a little bit.
This is kind of to the
world a lot of people
are sitting in right now.
And we do this as well, right?
Like, we do this for older OSes.
We have the virus.
We have antivirus.
We have our own
images from Mac OS.
images for Windows.
We're also constantly
upgrading those.
We're going to Patch
Tuesday stuff for Windows.
We issue the patches.
We do everything that your
companies are probably
doing to make sure that
that fleet stays up to date.
If you're not
doing those things,
you should probably be
doing those things on any
of your operating systems.
So we do go through this but.
We don't love this world, right?
We don't think this is the
modern way for people to live.
Again, it feels constraining.
It feels like busy
work that needs
to be done just for
the sake of security,
not really enabling
anything good.
So what we did is for
both Chrome and Android--
and here I will give the
example of using Chrome OS.
Chrome OS is actually fully
trusted out of the box.
Windows is not fully trusted
out of the box, right?
I cannot go and get it
off-the-shelf Windows laptop,
bring it in, and say,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
this is a Google laptop, and
then bring it to fully trusted.
It has to run our Windows image.
Mac OS has to run our Mac image.
Chrome OS does not run
a special Google image.
It uses the consumer
image, right?
This is why I'm giving this
example out of the box.
Same thing for Android--
do not have its own
image for Android,
runs the consumer image, yet
can get into fully trusted--
can get into that highest tier
of security for us, right?
Again, I'll just
reiterate to set
your intuition, Windows laptop
at home, using it at home,
great.
You can get into minimally for
sure, maybe even into mostly.
But to get into
fully, you're going
to always have to have an
image running from Google
in this particular case.
Chrome, that's not the case.
And that's because Chrome
and Android and iOS,
right, are running
in a more modern way
of doing operating systems.
And Chrome, in this case, has
verified boot TPMs, encryption
out of the box, sandboxing of
the actual processes, and all
of these things.
So verify boot, for
example, we feel
comfortable because we know
that the Chrome image is always
signed.
It has tamper protection.
It has tamper resistance.
And so we know it is always
using a Google signed
from the manufacturer
firmware image
on that particular device.
And we have the same thing
on Android now as well.
So you might don't know
this, but on Android,
if someone wants to flash
a custom ROM, et cetera,
you can absolutely detect
that through your EMM,
and either prevent it,
or you can say, well,
if someone has a custom ROM,
no fully trusted access, which
is what we do at Google, right?
So you have to be
using the manufacturer
ROM and the manufacturer OS.
We leveraged a TPM on Chrome
OS for storing secure keys.
So if we're going to give a
long-lasting identity token,
so this is something
we try and do in fully
trusted is you don't
want to be logging in
over and over and over and over
again for security purposes.
So we need a way to give
long-lasting identity
and long-lasting OAuth tokens
and identity tokens out
to the particular devices.
So by using the TPM
as the route of trust,
we're able to actually do
that with higher confidence,
rather than having really
important tokens sitting
in somewhere on disk where
that can be extracted and used
by an attacker, right?
So that's an important
thing is to have
a appropriate route of trust.
Processor sandboxing-- processes
sandboxing-- so inherently,
everything's run
its own process.
Those processes are
protected against each other.
So if you have a
piece of malware,
it's very difficult for it
to attack another process.
It's difficult for it to extract
data from another directory.
All of this is built in, again,
from the ground up by default
in modern operating systems.
There's a point there that
some of you may not understand,
which is we actually also have
the Play Store and Android
applications now
running on Chrome OS.
And that is also running
in a separate process which
is isolated from the main
kernel so that we can actually
make sure that we have
high enough security
from any Android app
that can be downloaded.
It does not interfere
with any of any
of the security on
the Chrome OS side.
And of course updates, right?
And this is a really
painful thing.
A lot of investment
going into here.
But on Chrome OS,
0% IT effort is
spent into managing
updates, managing patches,
like figuring out what's going
on or doing all those things.
We use the exact same
over-the-air, every-six-week
automatic update process that
a regular Chrome OS consumer
user would use, right?
Because everything is
baked into that cycle.
We can-- we don't here.
But just speaking for how
you can manage Chrome OS,
it has a full set
of EMM controls
that you can use with it.
You can delay those updates
because sometimes you
want to do verification
checking and testing and stuff
like that.
But because of the nature of
Chrome OS, because everything
is really running
through the browser,
because we're, once
again, cloud native,
our need to actually
go and say, oh,
let me test all my
applications is almost 0
because we don't have that
legacy application burden
that we do on other platforms.
So the benefits of this
approach is that it's
greatly simplified for IT.
We know that we're
secure by default,
so we're able to grant that
high tier of access to Chrome OS
and to Android just
out of the box, right?
And it has a wonderful
employee experience
because you can just get
up and running and not
have to worry about anything.
So I'll give you an example
of what I did yesterday.
You might have
noticed that we're
presenting from a lot of
Chrome OS devices here at Next.
But what happened
was, is I needed
to present from my laptop,
not this presentation,
but at a different
one somewhere else.
And so what actually happened
was I was like, well,
I have it all set
up on my laptop
and I could get
access to it up here.
And it's a privileged document
that I want to present,
a privileged site
that I need to get to.
So instead of saying, well,
how do I unplug this laptop
and plug everything in and get
it all working on the screen,
everything like that, all I had
to do was go to that device,
and I just said, log
in as a new user.
I've never logged into this
device before-- never, right?
I just said log
in as a new user.
Log in as Andrew.
It's already a privilege device.
I put in my security key.
I logged in.
I got all access to
everything immediately
from my own drive
and my own docs
and everything, pulled
up at the site I needed.
Pull up the site-- great.
Did my presentation.
Then logged out, said
destroy the session,
and everything is removed
from the Chrome device, right?
Completely secure-- but I
can use any Chrome device
in the Google fleet and--
I'm just saying--
within a minute,
I had that absolutely
set up to be me,
just the way I want it,
with all of my access, all
of my privileges,
everything I need.
So that's what we mean by
enhanced employee experience.
And again, we don't force
people to use Chrome.
It's a choice that
people can make.
They can get a Mac.
They can get a Windows device.
But there's some nice
advantages of using Chrome.
So this is another
example, Chrome Grab'n Go.
This is what I just said
but in the form of sometimes
I leave my laptop at home
because I'm absent minded.
And this happens
actually quite a lot.
So as long as I carry my
security key, what I can do
is we just have these massive
banks of Chromebooks that
just sit in every building.
And if you forget
your laptop, you
can just go, grab a generic
one, no IT interference.
You don't even talk to IT.
You don't even file a ticket.
You just grab it.
They're all getting
power right there.
You stick in your security key.
You set it up for yourself
just the way I just said.
You just log in basically
with your credential.
You use it all day.
And because I'm
a Chrome OS user,
it feels exactly the same as
using my own laptop, right?
I use it for the day.
When I'm done with it, I
just stick it back in there,
and I just put
the power back in.
And it says, OK, great.
Thanks for returning your
Chromebook, and I go home.
That's it, right?
So it's completely self-service.
It's completely secure.
We didn't make it secure.
It's literally just the
same as my own laptop.
The only reason I
have my own laptop
is because I just like the
idea of ownership, I guess.
But really, from actually a
getting-my-job-done standpoint,
there's no difference, literally
no difference between me using
my own laptop and using
one of these loaners,
other than the fact, I like the
idea that I have my own laptop.
So how do you take this-- we're
going to have plenty of room
for questions at the end.
I can take this
anywhere you want.
So how do we actually
plug this in?
Building a phased
approach-- so you definitely
want to start slowly
and start looking.
You don't want to just
revolutionize and change
your entire thing and say, we're
going to BeyondCorp at once.
But you want to say, how
do you build the best
experience for your users?
How do you make sure that
you've identified the users who
need access to things, gone
through your applications,
taxonomized your
applications, made
sure you know what
people are accessing,
and get all that
stuff under control.
You want to have a dedicated
team working with your devices.
I'm just guessing most
of you probably do
because you're in this session.
You're probably
part of this team.
But you do want
happy people who are
thinking about this every day.
Because if they're
not, once again, you're
not going to have a strategy.
You're just going to
have tactics, right?
So you want to have a
strategy for your organization
that's right for you.
We think that the concepts
I've talked about today-- again
they're high level.
But they apply to
95% of companies.
But that doesn't mean
you can just take them
and immediately do them.
You do need to make sure you
do the work to adapt them
to your company's needs.
So you need a team
who's working on that.
So in this particular
case, you do
need to make sure that
your security model also
transcends everything.
Again, where we are
is not somewhere
you can get to in one step.
We were cloud native
from the very start.
We had a shared security
model from the very start.
We have shared identity model.
We have a lot of
advantages here at Google.
We recognize this.
But you want to get to the
point where your security
team and your IT team are
on the same page in terms
of all this kind
of stuff and what's
going to be necessary for a
given application on any given
day at any given endpoint.
And within Google, debate rages
because we have the right tool
set with the tiered access.
But there's huge debate
and huge threads which say,
you know what?
Is it safe to give this
exact application access now?
It's always been fully.
But maybe now we
can get away with it
in mostly, because we have a new
signal for mostly devices that
allow us to feel more confident.
And then security and
IT will debate and talk
and collaborate for months.
And then we're
like, you know what?
Let's give it a try.
And we'll move its
access, and we'll
give it to it on a different
tier, and we'll try it.
So this is a live
strategy, right?
What I've talked about
today is more of a framework
for how you get there.
But putting the right
service in the right tier
is really important
because, once again,
otherwise the temptation
is just put it on fully,
don't trust anything else.
And you've gone back
to the binary days,
and you're not going to get
any benefit from the strategy.
Here, what you'll be able
to do, because you do this,
is, once again,
deploy services much
more quickly than you've
been able to before.
When you're worried
about malware
and all these kinds of things,
it actually greatly reduces--
and I gave that example
before for a reason.
It's actually very
confidence-boosting
to know that if you see
any threat, no matter what
the threat is, you can make
adjustments in your cloud
policy to make sure that
your surface area for attack
is greatly reduced,
without having to worry
about your endpoint fleet.
Because you always have that
issue where you're like, well,
what percentage of
my fleet is patched?
What percentage is
running this malware?
Can we reduce that?
Well, this person's
traveling, so we kind of--
What you want to
do is say, great.
All those things are
just facts of life.
But what you can actually do
is we can deploy the services
and put the security and
control in the cloud.
And by doing that, we
don't have to worry so much
about the actual
end state posture
because we know we're
still protected.
Yes, that individual user
might lose some access
to some services for a while.
But that's appropriate
and generally unavoidable.
You definitely have to
make good hardware choices.
Like I said before, this is
not about BYOD safe or no.
And people have come to me
because I'm Android guy,
and they're like,
Samsung, safe or no?
How safe compared to LG?
And I'm like, listen,
there's information
that can be shared amongst
all of these various things.
And I'll tell you exactly--
and if you were curious,
we can talk about exactly
where we've ranked
various devices here at Google.
But what we say is there's
a role for every device
in your actual-- when
you have tiered access,
there's a role for probably
pretty much every device.
Because even if they have
very low levels of trust,
you can give access
to some services.
It shouldn't be all or nothing.
And the more
services you can get
comfortable with
at that basic tier,
I think the better off
you're going to be.
But still, for those
higher tier stuff,
you want to make the right
hardware choices about which
platforms you support.
So ultimately this
is all moving towards
tiered, tiered, tiered, right?
Like, give yourself
and arm yourself
with this framework
and the tools
you need so your
job is just making
really clever insightful
decisions about where your risk
profile is and where you're
comfortable taking that risk,
not with what I see all
the time is people just
be constrained by that
example I gave before, right?
BYOD, safe or not safe?
If you're even thinking
about it in those terms,
it means you've tied your
own hands in your ability
to solve this problem.
And you will be forced to
deploy an imperfect solution
to the problem,
just by definition.
You just don't have the tools
you need to actually solve it,
right?
It's a hard enough question when
you have the tools you need,
right?
Because, again, we debate
all the time about what
should be on the BYOD
device versus not.
But if you just
have one big lever
for access and
not access, you've
already crippled yourself
in this standpoint.
So there's a lot of
nuance behind all of this.
And I don't want to necessarily
say this is a one-stop shop.
This is, like, a one-hour
session that you're all
hearing about this.
And this is years of
thought that we put into it.
We publish white papers
that you can read about it.
You can talk to your cloud
reps to hear more about
how we do it here at Google.
We have whole things
where our IT department's
able to share our
learnings, et cetera.
This is not just a, boom,
we've solved it, easy, buy
this product, you're all done.
That's not what I'm
here to tell you.
What I'm here to tell you is it
is relatively straightforward,
though, to go and talk about
within your company and say,
what's our overarching
strategy to endpoint access?
Do we have the strategy
we need to take us forward
for the next few years, where
device proliferation is just
going to be off
the charts, right--
off the charts.
Now is the time to be ready
for all the various devices
and access points that you're
going to have coming forward
as everything moves
into the cloud
and as we just
proliferate devices
to every single part
of the workplace.
And I have a whole
connected workspaces talk
that I get which is
not today, but where
I talk about where we see the
proliferation of devices going
and coming from.
So for you, there's
a few links here.
I apologize for the really
difficult links to type in.
But you can take a look.
Definitely google around,
look at BeyondCorp.
Look at some of our best
practice advisories,
read more about tiered access.
And these are areas that you
can do to familiarize yourself
more, further reading,
further homework
to see how you adapt this
to your own organization.
And we, as Google, are obviously
here to help you as well.
Because I think--
I will say that there's two
things when I joined Google
that really blew my mind.
I'm like, Google just
does so much better.
I've been here for
three years now, right?
And I've been in enterprise
mobility and security forever.
But there's two
products, which honestly,
as [INAUDIBLE], I'm like, blew
my mind about how good they
are here at Google,
where I'm like,
every company needs
to be like this.
One was video conferencing.
It has nothing to
do with this talk.
But I'll just give
you one of them.
Video conferencing is
really good at Google.
Every single meeting
has video conferencing.
Every single meeting is
just if you come in via VC,
totally part of the culture.
It takes like three seconds
to set of video conference.
Even ad hoc 101's are like,
hey, you want to meet?
Sure, let's meet.
Let's do a VC.
It takes me three seconds
to set that up, right?
Amazingly good at Google,
like blows my mind.
And the second area
is the approach
to endpoint security and access.
I've never seen such
a focus on security,
because it's Google,
and also such a focus
on getting as much access
all the time to our employees
and saying, no, more, more.
How can we step up
our security story
so we can give more to people
on lower tiers of access
while still remaining protected?
That is just built
into the culture.
And what that means
is as a Googler is
that you feel like you can just
focus on getting your job done,
right?
Never does my devices
and access really
feel like it's
getting in my way.
It just feels like I'm
always able to just get
stuff done, get stuff done,
which is really my job.
I really honestly, not
just because I work here,
feel like there's really
tremendous things that Google
has done very, very well.